[Applause]
[Music]
thousand revelers partying hard bill
Bavarian specialties brass Oompa music
and cheering crowds that's what the
Schottenheimer family has been providing
for five generations they can forget
their cares and worries for a whole day
and a night by spending a fun evening
here for an innkeeper it's something
very special to have satisfied customers
nobody comes from the family never
having taken themselves too seriously
while demanding a lot of themselves when
you handed that down through the
generations and I think it makes a
difference now I'm the fourth Machado
shaman but it took a while for me to
learn to do it right the family success
story began with the first major shot a
hammer in 1867 for they one hundred and
fiftieth jubilee their lives have been
chronicled in a commemorative book it
runs to two hundred and fifty pages
a human deviously I love the Oktoberfest
above all and I always go to
Schottenheimer
I love history too and it was just so
incredible to go into their story in
such depth the chaton Amoz have had
architects designed their tents since
the 1800s they used electric lights
early on among the odd job is screwing
in lightbulbs was a young Albert
Einstein the director of the Oktoberfest
Museum put the documents compiled for
the book into an exhibition we tell
every visitor who takes a tour with us a
little something about the shortened
ammos in addition to this exhibition
just because the tapping ceremony was
invented here the museum also shows old
film snippets of the second Misha is
Schottenheimer talking Munich's Meyer
into tapping the first kick in his tent
after the opening procession in 1950 my
friends with the mayor of Munich at the
time Thomas Verma who was riding in the
carriage with my grandfather and in the
carriage he said why don't you tap the
first cake now at that time tapping a
keg was actually beneath the dignity of
a man but he was a social democrat and a
man of the people so he stood there and
taptic
[Music]
and ever since the mayor has tapped the
first keg to mark the official start of
an 18-day party at the titty easy and
visa and nobody here has as much
experience at throwing a rousing party
as the Schottenheimer family
that is for Martha's mayavi the format
is really one of a kind where else do
you get so much together and it says in
a tent full of six thousand people and
everyone is focused on the brass band
music has an essential function at the
Oktoberfest and the band leaders like
Christian Zak's are the ones who really
get the party going
[Music]
salamati of course it's fun who else
gets the chance to control 6500 people
if you notice that a number isn't
getting a good response here it will
elsewhere you look down if a lot of
young people are here like on weekends
you can play something by ac/dc or
something great music great here it's so
laid-back here in the 1980s the bands he
has started playing other music besides
the traditional Bavarian folk that
helped make the Schottenheimer tent a
favorite among the younger set to stay
right on top of the tensions and
simultaneously keep the traditions what
soon to be developed or payment systems
for patrons so they can pay over their
cell phones because nowadays everybody
has their cell phone
this Schottenheimer family wants to
ensure that a beer in their tent remains
a must for every Oktoberfest goer